The role of the product manager has
changed dramatically in the last few
years, traditionally it was
just focus on execution,
making sure that the train
is running on time.
Now, the product manager has become
the mini-CEO of the product.
[MUSIC]
>> The Chief Product Officer Role is
a recent invention to recent development
that we're seeing, but this is where
businesses are going we will see more and
more chief product officers and
more and more companies.
And we'll see more and
more people who are growing up and
they want to be product people, and
we're here to help define what that is.
>> The product manager today needs to be
good at strategy, not just product product
strategy, but also corporate strategy and
making sure that they're aligned.
Making sure that the customer gets
the most positive experience,
the product manager needs to get very
deep level insights about a customer
at various stages of the customer journey.
The product manager has to be
effective at decision shaping,
shaping others decisions.
[MUSIC]
Especially of key stakeholders
within one's own organization,
many of whom are risk averse.
It's the first program targeted at
emerging chief product officers with a lot
of product management experience,
who have their eyes set on evolving
into the C Suite executive.
And the program is intended to
provide the right kind of skill sets,
the right kind of framework, the right
kind of real-world experiences to make
sure that they become more effective
as they merge into the C-suite.
>> Our program has both
an in-class component, but
also an out-of-class component that forces
our participants to go out there and
actively listen to customers in the
context of a workshop and come back and
actually create products based on
that listening process to customers.
>> Let us not ignore the fact that
we are in Silicon Valley, and
they will get a chance to get exposed
to the Silicon Valley mindset as well.
>> The Chief Product officer is not
simply managing the product, but
it's also coordinating the development and
the management of the product within
the organization all
the way up to the C suite.
This is not just a product manager but
it's really a product leader, this program
is intended for those people who want to
be the product leaders in their firm.
>> It is a long term relationship
that we are trying to create,
with future leaders in the world, who want
to make the difference, I mean all we can
do is provide the spark, it is the leaders
who want to go there and have the impact.